hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Lord minion 7/7 also
known as wait guys and we're gonna try
again with this whole deal and it looks
like this time we've started a new world
it looks like there's lush green grass
over there oh wait wait wait ring wait
one sec said please believe a tent you
to be what a doggie to you scream okay
I'll good the fam grass yes we know east
and then north east and north or west
west and north eat West what are you
what are you talking about man gonna go
to if you hit em and look at your map
we're gonna go up to that neighborhood
and then up to that other things oh
there was a map you did know there's a
map did I go there I feel like I might
have looked at this but I don't remember
it oh oh I get it that means oh that
makes so much sense okay where are you
wait why are we going due to the lemon
at the white car I'm coming I'm gonna
don't leave me behind
I'm actually like I know because some
people are you like like good progressed
a bit we're actually really gonna try
this time I'm not gonna like I don't
watch out for holes
floor remember I don't know I have no
excuse me for money looks like I have
found out that each biome is kind of
important for different reasons
yeah you need sand to make glass to make
more bottles and such okay blueberry so
I found blueberries that's good I pick
blueberries before and then I why is
this grass farting in my face I don't
know I swear it was really farting in my
face like it ate my world uh beer they
just break dirt I think I broke what on
the tree what am i hitting I win I broke
the wrong block of dirt ah can I just
say the ridiculousness of punching
things to break them is amplified when
it's not blocky minecraft like seriously
I know this game is kind of going for
realism so wouldn't our hands be
shattered into pieces by now you think
so
you think can you even make a shovel why
stop right here this is not breaking
what's going on damn anon I have no
water
oh that's gross damn gonna effects how
hard you can punch the swing Oh
oh that's I I think I think I knew that
but I didn't take it paid attention to
it wait there's no tree even here to
punch was bother to look out here what
is that I didn't even bother there was a
big tree now it's uh viewers can you do
a little bit of a rewind there and say
listen here are we just dot is that what
we left Abby you don't seriously don't
ask that question for me you do not want
to know the answer Wow Kelly use your
gun have a gun you know
maybe I don't know punch it Oh God I
have no stamina I can't hurt it oh I
just making a lot of out making a lot of
noises I'm very scared poured out there
good cop didn't even have anything what
is that supposed to be that's not
supposed to be here here what have a
sharpened stick is a weapon better than
nothing oh cool I didn't know you could
do this it doesn't look very sharp and
what what happened to our tree hahahaha
is happening okay where's our trees go
don't ask just get a new tree don't
worry about it we're gonna be fine don't
worry about can we get to the grass
biome because I feel feel very in danger
earlier yeah but we should have like
eight trees by now and hey just leave
hey I know it's hard but sometimes
please say goodbye by the way another
tip whenever you kill a zombie search it
because it will have pills or food on
its side I've been doing the nurses have
pills and the cheerleaders have Fong's
yes cheerleaders have fallen and
everyone knows that thongs are essential
for survival in those zombie apocalypse
yeah do not underestimate the usefulness
of a good thong Haven in daily life
right wait I mean you are thongs right
yeah yeah summit work every day
ha ha ha really explain to me how well I
don't leave works I probably just got
[ __ ] it's okay don't worry another
section of my map just missing who is
that a house house like a real house
house there's a lot of zombies in the
house house house should we kill now use
your stick aim for the head
oh dude buddy dick lady red yeah hello
baby my little green around the killer
put it behind us - okay
what oh my god this is a zombie
apocalypse not a fallout 3 ass thing
this is bull I don't like him either
apparently from what I gathered the game
was a little bit too easy because you
could just go onto a rooftop and be safe
so they added in Hornets and spider
zombies to climb did it add an L oh no
it simple I mean it's impossible just
because we're bad or I'm bad you're not
bad oh I am the one that screwed the
last ha ha ha you did indeed didn't you
okay so are we gonna hold out in this
house for what yeah that's fine we'll
try making it out here for a night okay
cool
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to not have to start over again let's
see that's the objective and survive one
night which just means one episode is
just gonna be pure terror
it's non-stop pair or I just cut it on a
diaper found water I found more water I
found a lot of water and hmm the kitchen
I got dog food yeah I got a kitchen
I'm doing it wait I'm doing it you're
doing it some water here have some water
I give it to you q just like minecraft
oh god I just
I should just think my grandma ate
basically thank you you're welcome
you're welcome you're welcome if I have
you're welcome
there's not another story I'm gonna tear
down the stairs on the outside so that
they say I'm gonna give you something
good like what open up the safe in the
wall I don't want it you do wanna do why
be happy you did
Oh help help
what I'm up I'm downstairs where are you
what are we talking about they're
downstairs yeah hello I'm right here
where are you there you are yeah I'm
right here what are you talking oh yeah
who's upstairs oh don't ask me how I got
there oh no Ace Ventura yeah I know it
was the Ace Ventura one so what am I
looking at okay the floor with the
kitchen what are the devil yeah what
about it there's a safe in there on the
wall
Oh open it up ah whoa zom zom uh we
didn't do a good job clearing these
things out did we I don't know how we
didn't I went through the floor with uh
ah oh I think they were on the roof
that's probably what it was you want to
get up here before I break this I was
gonna say I just fell through the other
side you keep falling in the holes man
there were holes there before I made a
hole we're gonna survive this
Wade you and me me and you up this roof
because the glass roof I do not trust
hey why was not to trust about it oh you
know the whole glass part last part okay
whatever you know what oh I see how did
you get up there there's a ladder on the
side
oh that's I don't I just need to walk
across and found it I'm low on health
this pills make health go big yes
tolls make it go bigger does make it go
real take it real beer
big we look at that we're talking about
health their minds out of the gutter huh
big hard sturdy health health bars big
red throbbing health bars wrong with you
up looking ass weird
oh I picked up a center of a chair why
are you yeah looks good hey you want to
sit in my chair it's a little art deco
Wade Wade you want where's you I stood
my chair oh that's a beautiful ever see
it didn't work I don't know why it
didn't work up a baby bothered art just
don't don't don't look at me for a
little bit okay good right good good
happy happy with the wave is happy happy
joy joy happy happy joy joy indeed
running stiffy you know that's one of
the shows that people tell me that I
need to watch again because when I watch
it as a kid you don't appreciate the
jokes for all you know you don't there's
like so many jokes in there that are
meant for adults watching it but I knew
when I was a kid that that show was
meant for adults yeah I mean yeah I did
too and that's why my dad didn't let me
watch it I mean then they made the Ren &
Stimpy was like the adults only version
but that was kind of dumb anyway okay
how do I make torches alright so do you
know how to make sticks yes is like
minecraft sticks right what sticks in
the very middle of your crafting table
wait how do I make sticks on I didn't
know my mix sticks would put wood in the
middle yeah you should get old plywood
or got plywood right I got I would put
plywood in the middle okay that should
you stick oh I like actual plywood
plywood oh I got you oh I see that's a
lot of sticks man yep put those in the
middle and put any slot fragments you
have on top you can also use coal but we
don't have any kolya I don't have cloth
practice here what there you go right
here all right oh cool yeah now that I'm
getting started wait I didn't really go
there on it now that I'm getting stored
of them quite a bit there we go okay
it's got to be in the dead center right
yeah okay alright now that I'm getting
the basic gist of it do these last
forever by the by I think so I've never
had one run out
but then again I can't say we played
long enough to find out
it's almost cozy in here this is
actually nice yeah don't say that I
heard I heard a sound it sounded
menacing we'll be okay the first night
oh it's not even what was later than
this you sure we'll be okay
hurry never sure you got to fall through
the floor again into a pity despair my
father why is there a floating chair
what did you build in here i-it's Art
Deco don't make fun of my arm
it's useless deco you're useless deco
don't talk to me like that ah Rick
whatever Shan you think you know what's
best but you do not you think you're the
family but they're wait I'm the baby God
love me you know that that makes the
fact that you slept with Laurie all the
more awkward how'd you do us living
Laurie I saw season one oh you got
walkie dead on DVD here Wow it all the
time my favorite show golly gee
willikers holiday fine as always we
should be board up these windows are we
good well me if you got extra wood it
doesn't hurt to uh yeah I'm gonna like
punch the window out first though I
always got extra wood for you we should
just take the windows rather than have
to break them yeah maybe there's a way
these do not last long by the way is
this kind of like oh yeah alright so
night is approaching do we just stay in
here and hold up until don't basically
you stay in here and you twiddle your
thumbs for a while kind of like
Minecraft except in Minecraft you can
actually dig down in mine we actually
you know what we might be able to hear
mine yeah you want to try through the
floor I mean it's something to do yeah
might as well yeah I got another noon
you stop that just wood Karl's not
really yours no you don't sound too
disappointed there Rick
come on give me more feeling more
feeling Rick oh you get to pay the child
support I'm gonna win
what are the people gonna realize that
we just sometimes go too far no no we
have a got too far yet once we go too
far well we just put out a drunk
minecraft where we've put nipple penises
on Jesus that'll do you have I'm pretty
sure I have no oh wait no I do have
criminal what do we need with it can we
build a shovel you can build a shovel
and a pick axe oh you kidding me geez yo
give me here what you doing is your
inventory you see you have at least like
12 scrap metal I have four I'll have
four there makes seven what if we punch
seven with your punch the fridge where
we ponch it if we punch it break it down
well stuff you can try I'm not gonna try
you gonna make me look like an image
image right here ya dig yeah alright can
you pour up these windows get on here up
on the first floor yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah any more wood no no baby
no no baby yeah what Oh skull wait baby
does she not work ah where the old oh
don't tell me about that back when you
had your robots when I used to touch the
fro oh oh yeah the problem that's a
reference no one knows cuz nothing ever
happened to that thing ever it's a
mystery reference that we're never gonna
talk about again cuz nothing happened
hm like that Seinfeld episode just shut
up okay anyway we're gonna get to this
in the next episode but we actually have
some potential here to actually succeed
so I'd agree
anyway thank you all so much for
watching we're all the time for this one
thank you wade once again check out wage
channels in the description for the his
point of view of the not derpy version
of him actually doing stuff and we will
continue this in the next one hope
you're enjoying it so thank you all so
much for watching click news
it is that I've done now as always Oh
see you in the next video
bullets
bullets now avoid Savannah can they gun
now
well actually Crouch I can't
Oh seems like this FPS free energy